[Music]
they're about a million things with this
wedding that aren't going as planned
it's a case of life imitating art as
Megan Markos real-life big day is also
experiencing some last-minute pickups on
Monday a report surfaced at Megan's
father Thomas Marco will no longer walk
her down the aisle to marry Prince Harry
and now a source tells ET her dad's
choice has left Megan devastated adding
quote this was his decision entirely the
move comes after the Daily Mail reported
that Thomas Marvel worked with a
photographer to stage paparazzi photos
ahead of the Royal Wedding despite the
allegations against her dad our source
says Megan would still like him to come
on Saturday if he stays at home and he
breaks Megan's heart by doing that
that's an unforgivable betrayal far
worse than what he's done with these
pictures on Tuesday The Daily Mail's
Piers Morgan spoke to ET about Markel's
dad dropping out of the wedding
following the scandal and address
reports that Thomas suffered a heart
attack I'm afraid I don't buy the heart
attack I think that was designed to make
us feel sympathy for him I'd imagine
he's probably suffering a bit of anxiety
both about the enormity of the wedding
but also his own behavior which has been
frankly deplorable you know my sympathy
is not with Thomas Markel here it's with
Megan Markel he has ruined the build-up
to his own daughter's wedding and if I
were him the only thing you can do now
to repair this is get on a plane and
walk your daughter down the aisle
[Music]